so to me what's more promiscuous than
taking off your clothes for money if you
want to be up and down a pole and make
money for it but you're not sleeping
with anyone to me that's not her because
you could sleep with two people in your
lifetime I'd be throwing it back for
money I don't think that makes you a
hurt do you do you think the majority of
women that are taking off their clothes
for money are super selective with who
they sleep with probably not if a
woman's selling her body for money yeah
she's a [__] would you say you're
equally as promiscuous as a stripper
so is that offensive yes or no and is it
true yes or no
offensive yes true no it's not true I
don't think strippers are not hoarse I
don't think so okay yeah I don't think
so either but it's offensive it's a you
don't think it's true I don't think it's
true
I don't think it's true and I suppose it
can be offensive depends who's so
strippers are not hoarse I don't think
so no okay
I don't think it's all true and I think
it's only offensive if you're either a
horror stripper
tell me why is it not true
because to me a horror is someone that's
promiscuous right so to me what's more
promiscuous than taking off your clothes
for money then you could say any person
that post is a bikini pic on Instagram
as a whole yeah I would say that too but
I mean my definition
is if you're having sex with multiple
people throughout a short period of time
consistently I would call you a hoe I
would put them in that category too oh
yeah 100 they're at the top of the
category for me but if you decide to go
in if you want to be up and down a pole
and make money for it but you're not
sleeping with anyone to me that's not
her because you could sleep with two
people in your lifetime I'd be throwing
it back for money I don't think that
makes you a hoe do you think the
majority of women that are taking off
their clothes for money are super
selective with who they sleep with
in general not not I know there's
exceptions but in general
probably not however there are there is
the exception but but as a general
statement it's kind of true
I don't know I still I still don't think
it's true personally I don't know no
okay why am I wrong
I just feel like calling strippers I
don't know it's like like she said I
feel like they could be quite selected
for who they're sleeping with they're
not necessarily hoes because just
because they're throwing a bag for money
doesn't mean that they're out there
sleeping with multiple men and we don't
know their circumstances like we don't
know why they're stripper they have
their reasons if you're a robber but you
have your reasons for being a robber it
doesn't make you not a robber
okay you got me there
um
it still makes you a rubber because you
stole at the end of the day but
stripping is just it's different it's
like
if they if they're stripping is
promiscuous yes or no no no
you don't think taking off your clothes
for money and putting your boobs in a
stranger's face is promiscuous I mean
that's not not at all I mean shaking ass
and like a stranger okay any man can pay
fifty dollars and your boobs are in
there in their face it's not a little
okay it depends I feel like it that's an
extent to stripping like there's some
that fully undressed and then there's
the ones that you know cover a little
bit so I think I think there's a certain
level to it right well but we're talking
about in general not not there's except
you know there's the I'm sure there's a
virgin stripper out there yeah that's
that's what I'm saying so I don't think
they're necessarily hurts like their
virgin strippers so I promise kiss good
in general in general would you say
they're more promiscuous yeah than the
average girl sitting on my couch would
you say you're equally as promiscuous as
a stripper the thing is you can't tell
because
like
that's triple like you you can't tell
you just can't tell like I could see
someone on the train fully clothed and
in like on underneath she could be
sleeping with like 50 men wear as a
stripper like just because she's naked
or like you know okay so if one guy's a
pickpocketer right and there's another
guy that robs banks for a living right
does that make the make the first guy
not a pickpocketer
like just because there's someone that's
a worse robber than him like aren't they
still all robbers
you know just because one's worse you
know one's Robin Banks right he could be
Robin Banks
but he's just pickpocketing he's not
he's not putting a gun out I
don't know I honestly can't say I just
feel like calling strippers like more
promiscuous than others it's just a bit
much okay is it true it's not true it's
not true not even a little true
no okay all right okay um I think that
the word [__] comes from back in the
days when it's like another word for
prostitute so if a woman's selling her
body for money yeah she's a [__] but
these strippers
yeah I agree with you
um but these strippers are not having
sex they are 100 promiscuous like
there's no way you can get go from that
you know they're trying to promote sex
sexuality she's shaking her head I think
it's promiscuous I think that her whole
thing is cut I can't lie worth fifty
dollars
but realistically you could be on a
train with someone and they could have
taken wood that morning but their
dresses
no but I could if you could have someone
that's a stripper she's tripping to get
through night school if she's got 50
boobs Fair pages of having good boobs
you can profit off it that doesn't make
you promiscuous though what does
promiscuous mean
promiscuous I mean you don't know what
promiscuous means it's the taking off of
the clothes
I agree with you
like you know strippers I wouldn't say
it's only sex sexual yeah energy
attention feelings thoughts
I mean there's nothing wrong with it
they're they're holding their hands up
say yeah this is what I'm doing for
money they're not sleeping with guys
there's nothing wrong being promiscuous
we are sexual beings as humans so I'm
saying some people have different levels
so it's not a bad thing that shippers
are promiscuous that's what like
um thing that they're in what field
they're in sex would you since they're
not promiscuous would you be okay with
your boyfriends going to a strip club
every day but they're not promiscuous
don't worry yeah because I'd be going to
one too you'd be okay
I honestly would not be okay why not
it's just they're like nuns in there no
they're not I'm not saying they're nuns
I'm just saying they have their reasons
it's like the average like I mean it's
the same as the girl on the train no I
just feel like certain strippers have
their reasons for what they're doing
like that could be the only source of
income or they could have set in
circumstances as to what they're why
they're doing so but personally like I
would not want my boyfriend to go to a
strip club I
but the reasons like it still doesn't
take away from the fact that they're
doing what they're doing because
remember a guy could be homeless right
he but he doesn't have the option to go
down to the strip club and get a job he
just has to go get a real job at Subway
the stripper could do that
she just chooses not to she wants easy
money
she might enjoy it yeah yeah that's a
horse like easy money for their bodies
I mean yeah 100 however they might it's
you can't say that no one likes Easy
Money everyone wants to make money in an
easy fashion if someone could say if
someone gave you an opportunity not
necessarily to be promiscuous but
another another opportunity that was
quite respectable and it was easy money
you would take it because everyone wants
to make money easily the fact that these
in these individuals decide do you know
what I'm gonna be naked because it's
easier fair play at it I mean I could I
could sell drugs for easy money you know
but it's like at what cost right and
everyone's got a moral framework and I
would say definitely when it comes to
their bodies Horrors care less about
selling them
so
is I don't I don't see it as selling
though necessarily I for me what are the
men paying for
for the visual of what
[Laughter]
it's like this isn't water wet like guys
you guys know I'm right
she she's she's based a little bit yeah
no I actually know what it is because
obviously we're not disputing why
they're doing it you know people
sacrifice whatever it is what it is
because I'm saying they're selling their
bodies you know for money for sexual
these guys are getting sexual pleasure
out of it they're not like dancing to
make these men think about oh yeah I'm
gonna go to the bank do this for my job
like it's a thrill it's an excitement I
mean it is what it is though there's
nothing wrong with it so sex is like the
biggest industry I think after is it
before after it
one of them hmm
it's really after I T is bigger than the
second one I'm surprised it's not sex
first yeah it's one of them what it's
between those two Auntie what do you
think um are strippers [__]
yes or no I'm still with the fifth was
it five fifties on the boobs yeah like
you just they pay 50 I don't know what
they cost you know when you said that um
let me know in the chat guys how much
did you pay for your last lap dance I
don't know the real cost I was just 40
kids just say something totally up
subject
once you said that you got a fantastic
pair of boobs thank you
you are wearing a decent bra you have to
there's no spillage I love that when you
said 50
what I saw was her boobs I just took up
my glasses and my eyes still will go in
there I couldn't help it because she got
fantastic yeah I love that so yeah must
be nice um
I personally think that um they are
selling
they said insects no matter how but
I I know some that um
that go there with their man's blessing
because to them it's just a way of just
going and getting some money let us go
and take it off and do whatever some
people really get into it so some people
it's like clocking in clocking out
but it's still in the sex industry and
that's what's selling
so yeah so yeah they are horse
I think the ones that sleep with men are
[__] and the ones that don't sell in
sex I agree so you've got strippers and
you've got stripper horse you don't
think you don't think it's a [__] if
you're literally being paid to take off
your your bra and put them in random
men's face
to me that's
if you if you that's what I said there's
some of them are a [__] those ones are
horse but you've got some that just
don't come off the pond and don't come
off the stage yeah some some people do
that just because they some women find
it empowering
believe it or not
but it's all in the sex interesting it's
all set in sex so so yeah sex sellers so
at the end of the day what's it what's a
sex seller guys what's a sex seller or
um this okay so this tweet got so many
views okay I even got the attention of I
was so excited I got the attention of um
Logan Paul's friend I'm trying to find
the Tweet I've been tweeting so much
this week yeah but he dated Lana Rhodes
you know what I'm talking about
Mike something you know what I'm talking
about blessing yeah Mike something and
he tweeted back at me calling me a [__]
back I was like how much did you charge
him
on the podcast let's do it so open
invite to Mike um I don't know your last
name I just know you as Logan Paul's
friend
um anyways
speaking of Horrors famous [__]
who is the most famous [__] that you
can think of go Kim Kardashian good one
go
yeah kind of a different one I say Amber
Rose Amber Rose different one
what's her name
can I say you can call this is the
system
[Laughter]
I can't think of anyone you just say
Kardashians in general yeah Kardashians
okay I was hoping for a different one
but okay go ahead and I'm old school so
I'm gonna say
Dita Fontes
I don't know who that is exactly
you know who I think of that Hillary
Monica Lewinsky
okay that's the most famous horror of
all time you know she was in her knees
in it yeah yeah she she made a book out
of it but she didn't actually have sex
though did she that's what she said then
what was it you said these famous words
he's famous words I did not have sexual
relationships with that woman Auntie she
has sexy relationships with him that's
what you meant
you think they didn't have sex
maybe he just they just went to Second
yeah
he's giving head second base Third Base
I don't know
someone said Larissa Pippin in the chat
okay so
now that we have agreed that I'm right
thank you guys
um
strippers are [__]
um oh actually one more only fans models
are they [__] yes or no
when you say models as in their content
as well yes just themselves like if you
were to say the average only fans model
[__] yes or no no no
Yeah Yeah from the definition like we're
talking yes yes from what it says that
I've never seen it only fans but I'd say
yeah and it's the same as stripping but
on online pretty much but you can you
can just like basically take a nude and
send it to someone or use toys
but again it's completely virtual you're
not you're not doing anything with
someone else so you could be a virgin
isn't it some of that it's porn yeah but
some porn stars are husband and wife so
how how many bodies does it take for a
girl to become a [__] I don't think is
the body count I think it's the
frequency the for okay how frequent so
any multiple guys in a year how many how
many till [__] and how long is she a
[__] for can she ever
yeah 100 okay so in a year how many
bodies till she is officially [__] I
just think we should nail it down
I think if you have sex with more than
one guy a week that's different
you're a [__] I thought you were going
to say a year I was like for a year a
week so no more than no more than
I'd say you should no more than really
ten no more than 10 in a year yeah okay
okay so if she has more if she has 11 in
a year [__] yeah I draw the line at 11.
horror okay what about what about the
next year she has zero was she still a
[__] she's she's rejuvenated
she's a born-again [__] definitely okay
what about what about how many in a year
uh I feel like it's hard to put a number
in it but I don't know yeah like 10 to
think 10 in a year yeah like I don't
know
if you stop being sexually active and
like completely and you don't sleep with
anyone then yeah
not really a [__] anymore yeah born
again all right what about you what
about you how many in a year I say more
than three personally more than three in
a year yeah all right no you can't undo
being a [__] definitely I mean you
can't or you can't you can't yeah energy
yeah you can undo it passes to pass yeah
not to men unfortunately yeah you're a
[__] forever yeah if you ask the guys
I'm telling you ask a guy the same
question also
be like 10. I thought they meant that
for a lifetime all right that's why I
thought when they said 10 I'm thinking
that's one a month of two months to
recover
that's I I look so and two I I think as
she has more than two
but if you can be a Boon again I want to
be a virgin
[Laughter]
do you know what I mean I don't see how
it works
okay so I have I have some stats for you
guys some fun fun stuff okay here it is
all right according to a 2017 survey
conducted by the Center for Disease
Control and prevention the average
number of sexual partners in American
adults reported having in their lifetime
or in the UK but usually the numbers are
similar how how many average Partners do
you think the average woman has in her
lifetime guess on average yeah according
to the CDC
say 30.
seven seven this is nothing to do with
me guys it's not my numbers but I think
50 50. I don't say five on average in a
lifetime yeah
you're the Accord according to to what
the women say which let's be honest
let's
4.2 wow that's good that's good so
that's a 0.2 of a person well I think
it's the average so if you know in a
lifetime 4.2 yes is that the new gen or
the object why is it worth 2017
2017. yeah no I don't think they should
them stats are not good they should come
ask people today because I think black
cultures change people say much more
Freer with sexual partners and stuff
what what's changed what do you think
like I think that women are a lot more
free-minded with having sex with random
guys and multiple guys like it's okay
for them to sleep with more people where
obviously back in the day like 2017
sleeping with one one man was enough so
yeah I think those stats they don't they
don't count anymore or would you mean
multiple guys you said random or
multiple yeah like more than one guy
like at the same time some I don't know
no because when you said random you can
have loads of random when she said
multiple
these people just literally linking
people to have sex so you're thinking
well it must be about 15 is that average
now I said 50 babe 50 yeah like from
what I see from the culture and how
people move in I really do think that
that's more of a realistic number yeah
so let's let's do some math here okay so
the average the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31. okay how long
do you think someone would date before
they get married like two years would
you guess yeah two to four years two to
four years so let's say she meets so 30
29 28 12 I'd say at 27 off the market
with the same guy
how many bodies did she get up to 27
would you say guess
average girl in the UK living in London
let's say London because London's going
to be different than like the other side
of England to average hour I'd say maybe
12. 12
. but before didn't you say the average
number was 30 now I'm talking based on
today's statistics of a 27 year old in
London I feel like it's down to 12. I
feel like by 27 she could have on
average I'm trying to even it out like
12 12. an average 20 to 27 I would say
like five six five six yeah Thirty
Thirty Thirty Auntie what do you think
[Laughter]
when she comes out of high school she
would have had 20 by the time she does
this but she's finished College he's not
surprised and uni students it's like an
old yet there isn't it
yeah so why are we so hesitant to call
okay so
I don't have him in front of me so I'm
gonna be butchering this but if you're a
virgin on your wedding night and this to
be fair the stat is from a more Catholic
organization so you can take it with a
grain of salt but if you're a virgin on
your wedding night what do you think
your chance of a happy marriage is
um
I think a lot less than if he was to
have sex prior to marriage a lot a lot
you're less likely to be happy if you're
a virgin yeah okay why do you think that
because a lot of other a relationship is
sexual compatibility now I speaking on
myself I've been in situations where
you've not you've prolonged sex with
someone had sex with them and now
everything's just not good anymore no I
don't want to see you anymore because
there's no compatibility you have to you
have to know and understand a person
sexually before you can commit to them
for the rest of your life how did how
did you know how would you know they're
bad if you've never been with anyone
else because you know you know what
feels good enough what doesn't feel good
and when you were a virgin did you you
did you feel like the person you were
like the first person you had sex with
was bad
no looking back on it now he did all
right to be fair yeah okay okay so what
about you versus virgin well you didn't
say a percentage what percentage
um what percent of that you wouldn't be
happy no would be like what percent have
happy marriages of virgins on their
wedding night
say about 25 25 okay I don't know for me
I just feel like you can't base your
happiness and marriage just based on the
sex though no so they take they take you
know how many partners did you have
before marriage they fill out the survey
and then they say are you happily
married after 10 years so it's like what
percent of a hundred women are happy
after 10 years that are virgins on their
wedding night
yeah like again I just don't do you
agree do you do you think virginity has
any impact on the happiness of a
marriage no I don't you don't so it
doesn't matter if you've had a lot or a
little yeah could have what about a
hundred Partners okay 100 Partners
that's yeah okay that could definitely
affect your happiness emerged but
if you're a virgin I don't see how it
would necessarily affect your happiness
because you don't necessarily know how
it feels okay what do you think I think
like more like 80
um because it's sacred and I think that
the man the husband would cherish his
wife a lot more
um and they grow together they learn
together and usually if you're married
as a virgin you're young you know what I
mean so if they're not going to be happy
in the relationship it's not because of
the sex it's the emotional and mental
thing but yeah I think they'll be a lot
more happier I'll get married as a
virgin okay Auntie I think you'll be
high as well because you've got nothing
to compare it with and you know you
can't say he's rubbish because you don't
know how rubbish he is you just think
that's it
so again this is from a more Catholic
organization so you can take it with a
grain of salt but 80 chance of a happy
marriage if you're a virgin on your
wedding night
you know there's free drinks
um so where
when do you think it changes so what
number of Partners do you think a girl
goes from typically being happy to being
unhappy
unhappy in what sense
um so again they say how many partners
did you have before marriage she says
two three four five ten twenty where do
you where do you see the number changing
um a lot basically I actually saw
something and it said that if you've
slept with more than 25 people by the
time you get married you have a higher
chance of divorce I don't know how
factual that is but um
okay so you think 25 roughly okay what
do you think
I'm trying to think
um
I'll see you in like 10 10 okay
yeah I'll say like 30 I think obviously
it affects the man and his ego and
which is not a bad thing which you know
what I'm saying he emotionally treat her
a certain way and always have this like
hangover so yeah maybe 38 38 what do you
think I can't remember a question how
many how many partners until it affects
a girl's mouth oh okay that's why I
wouldn't say that percentages
before marriage can I just answer that
can I say anything above two the
basically
yeah I was gonna say two I was gonna say
Third Time Lucky after two just get
married
yeah so
um after two it significantly goes down
it's like like 80 guys please don't
butcher me in the chat I know I know
it's like it goes down to roughly 50 but
after five Partners you have a 20 chance
of being in a happy marriage
so you go from an 80 chance to a 20 25
chance
how crazy he's just off the five
yeah because what are the odds that
that's you know the best you can do
right like that the guy the fifth one is
the one you're happy with like what was
wrong with the first second third and
fourth so maybe you're just never happy
I have no chance of marriage I just
thought to please
okay uh we are gonna react to an Amber
Rose clip oh wait but first first should
I read the Super Chat I'm trying to be
better guys
um if you have a comment guys all right
I need to have a talk with you
sometimes guys we need to be nicer in
the chat all right
um look I really
I'm gonna read them now and I I don't
actually even know what you guys put
because I haven't been watching
please don't make me say things where I
feel awkward all right like it's not fun
for me it's not fun for you well it's
very fun for you I could see the draw
but I'm just really looking forward to
having a bit nicer they if you got stats
questions thoughts that's fine but
personal attacks we're gonna try to stay
away from but you know you paid for
these so I'm gonna read them but you
know moving forward okay
Doug Bagley the difference is modern day
gardening tools are giving away their
value for free LOL you can have sexual
compatibility and still have a horrible
relationship zentians oh hi zentians um
fun fact sentience was my first super
chatter I when I did my first show a
year ago he was the first one to give me
like a big super chat and I was I kept
going so he's been here for over a year
zentians women should and do have the
freedom to act like 304s but what should
not be allowed nor tolerated is
accepting them as they are hoes don't
want to give the same acceptance to men
if you were 304 stay on that corner and
accept the consequence the blackest
Panther sleeping around is not the only
thing that makes you a 304 having 304
friends supporting 304 behavior and
putting thirst traps online are all 304
Behavior
which by default makes you a 304 dragon
stallion1001
would a woman marry a guy that is 25 000
in debt no you wouldn't that's the way
the men look at bodies for women each
one puts a thousand dollars in debt so
why is it bad for a man not to want to
marry a woman with 25 bodies 25 times a
thousand equals 25 000. yeah fun fact I
asked guys would you rather have a girl
with fifty thousand dollars in debt that
you have to pay off or 50 bodies all of
them pick the debt obviously yeah yeah
well if you're wondering um sentience um
just stopping by to show support you
cannot become unbecome a 304 as time
goes on she's just an older 304. just
like a murderer cannot be born again
there will always be one women always
try to re rewrite their sordid pass
gents focus on yourself Joe body count
LOL not frequency Michelle people keep
redefining what a prostitute is uh
delusional Maka rocks up Pearl it's
important to dis address the fact that
the law distinguishes between
prostitution stripping sure some who
strip are not prostitutes at all Carlos
strippers are 304s they dry hump for a
for money a minute humble shark 25
um I've watched 30 shows and I'm not
subscribed wait am I subscribed damn it
um B Panther 101 you always have a
choice you can make other way there's
other ways you can make money besides
selling your soul for money people want
to take the easiest way out and it's
going to make things harder along the
Route or along the line controversial
videos and gym all the strip clubs at my
City sell uh
p word for fifty dollars um blackest
Panther would you be okay with a man
visiting a strip club every day I mean
they're not 304s and they're also more
promiscuous so what's the issue he's
just trying to understand them from the
inside out
um a scout and Brandy I have dated
strippers and yeah they are 304 as
privates and in the military Mary
strippers and go and ask them if their
wives are 304s I'm Alex hey Pearl first
time donating I love the show ladies uh
please rate yourself one through ten if
you were a seven
um and uh Pearl get the wet wipes out
okay we can do that rate yourselves one
to ten what do you think you are ten ten
YouTube there's no room for improvement
you're perfect
yeah my mom went through nine months of
Labor to give birth to a perfect child
so I definitely say 10. so did everyone
yeah so I rate myself there's not no
room for improve who do you think's a
time in Hollywood
hmm
that's a good question
for me Chris Brown Chris I know a girl a
girl oh
Megan Good okay I'm gonna ask you two
questions do you think you could attract
Chris Brown because you're on the same
level
I have a great personality 100 do you
think you and Megan Good are on the same
level
in different ways okay you have 10 10 in
Hollywood I'm gonna put mine until an
8.5 an eight point Who's I feel like I
have I can improve myself okay who's
another 8.5 uh in Hollywood yeah
Hollywood TV whatever oh that's a good
question so if a 10 is Megan good that's
a good one she I would say she is 9 10.
so slightly below Megan good you know
slightly
[Music]
I really can't Chloe Kardashian I don't
know
never mind
um I really can't think of anyone right
now
no one out of the whole world
my line is this black right now I can't
think it's an English it's an English
models the black one no me yeah Naomi
Campbell okay you know I've met her fun
fact
no no I would coordinate like an eight
nine I feel like she's still at ten she
looks good hey what about Lori Harvey
where she
oh oh she's gorgeous she's definitely a
10 out of 10. okay is there anyone
that's not a tenants
uh what about
um someone told me that have you seen
Saved by the Bell
um I don't know I don't know yeah okay
blessing who would you say is an 8.5
wanna let's get a guy's point of view
I'm very kind of tough so I'll say like
Megan Good is 8.5 to me she's not a 10.
okay he says you and Megan Good the same
no no but I would say Megan Good is a
it's a 10 okay what about you who's an
eight oh an eight
um
I say Georgia Smith
who Georgia Smith
she's UK I'm gonna I'm gonna go I need I
need to get a Georgia Smith she's
gorgeous okay
so you and her the same she's yeah
obviously she's got millions of pounds
which if I had I'd definitely be looking
after my buddy but yeah she's a
beautiful being okay who's a five auntie
foreign
she's a five
Auntie she's old and she's a five
can I just say that you've got an
absolutely beautiful face okay so I
wouldn't give yourself a five I think
you should definitely Mark that up a bit
but just on my face you've seen the rest
of my books
yeah no no no no no no but she's better
than me
God is
ready
I think we're both fives no you're not
yourselves okay well you know I
I've got room for improvement there a
bit both freezing I've got room to make
on my way until five okay do you think
being a five is an insult
me to average really doesn't it yeah
okay I don't think it's an inside for
average no what about you
um
is an insulting to be average I mean if
someone told me I wasn't five yet yeah
you'd be insulted me into it no I'm like
because some of us are five some of some
of us are ones some of us are tens okay
yeah staney Lane okay I'm gonna do
something that's just nice anyway I
think it's insulting that they're trying
to push me somewhere where I'm not
they're trying to if I say that I'm same
as I'm a number five I think that's why
you don't listen to him because they lie
to you because he's like trying to say
no you've got a nice friend I think
you're a six that's one more point up
that's a lot that's a that's a lot of
people's skin you've got lovely eyes
you're really mysterious and gorgeous
okay we're not comparing you to a 20
year old we're comparing you to your age
no no no no no by the way we're not
comparing you for your age oh we're not
we're comparing a 10 is a hot model a
one is an 90 year old lady yeah so
that's good and the five is half that
yeah
so I'm still gaining okay so um one
I'm gonna I'm gonna do something all
right you rate everyone oh
my gosh
everyone in the room yeah everyone in
the room you can write me too I won't
get offended okay
I would give you
a seven wow I'm excited okay go ahead
I'd give you
7.5
I'll give you an eight thank you
I'd give you a 6.5
do I have to write blessing as well no
no just a minute no just a moment okay
yeah anti-rate everyone
five
yeah six six five six five
great everyone
eight
seven
six okay right everyone six
five five
eight six did anyone give anyone else
other than Auntie did anyone give every
anyone else a five
interesting isn't it just interesting
how like no one's average
but like someone's got to be average
I'm not in a room you know I'd like I'd
like one day to have a program where
we've got loads of wet wipes and then
when people say that we make them take
off all their makeup
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible